ja meine These ist eigentlich nichts
anderes als wieder eine Statistik da
kann ich nichts für das ist nun mal mein
Job und da von äh bin ich sozusagen
nicht befreit wir haben wir haben das ja
eben schon gesehen Armutsbekämpfung ist
natürlich ein wirklicher Aufgabe des
Staates und das ist der Aufgabe des
Sozialstaates dennoch muss man immer auf
mit dem Tablet bei einem Teppich bleiben
wir haben im Moment die reichsten Abend
die dieses Land jemals gehabt hat wir
haben auch die reichsten reichen äh das
ist schon klar aber irgendwo muss man
das auch relativieren wir haben ein
Sozialstaat der im Grunde genommen die
Wertschöpfung jetzt zu etwa ein Drittel
abgreift das heißt ein Drittel dessen
was wir an Wertschöpfung produzieren in
Deutschland wird für Soziales ausgegeben
das ist eine Quote die noch nie in
unserem Land historisch gesehen zu Hofer
wir kennen weltweit nur ganz wenige
Länder die uns da das Wasser reichen
können wir sind der Sozialstaat der
ausufern der Sozialstaat der auch
tatsächlich jetzt an seine Grenzen stößt
sie müssen sich vorstellen die meisten
Komponenten unseres Sozialstaats sind im
Grunde genommen nicht
kindesarmutsbekämpfung sondern die
größten Ausgabenposten gehen an die
alten und die alten werden mehr
sie müssen ja nur mich anschauen ich bin
zum Beispiel einer derjenigen die eine
riesen Last darstellen die
Pensionslasten der Beamten die wenden
lassen die entsprechenden
gesundheitsversorgungslasten die
entsprechenden pflegeausgaben natürlich
auch die Ausgaben für Grundsicherung die
sind auch explodiert wir haben überall
explosive Mischungen von Sozialausgaben
wenn wir über ein Drittel der
Wertschöpfung gehen heißt das auf gut
deutsch dass wir unseren Kindern
erklären müssen irgendwann wenn sie
selbst Beitragszahler sind bitte gebt
uns von eurem Gehalt 30 % für die Rente
gibt uns vor eurem Gehalt aber 25% für
die Gesundheitsversorgung von meiner
Generation also unsere Generation
sauberer ja gibt uns dann 7% für die
Pflege gibt uns dann noch ein bisschen
was für Arbeitslosenversicherung und
sonst was und wenn wir dann unseren
Kindern klopfen und sagen da zwei
Drittel dann für den Sozialstaat drin
das ist gut dass das ein Drittel
Steuerschuld noch reinpasst dann werden
wir ein Akzeptanzproblem bekommen der
Sozialstaat ist an seine Grenzen
gestoßen bei den jungen Generationen die
jungen Generationen wissen dass der für
sie so nicht akzeptabel ist und deshalb
müssen wir als Generation der Babyboomer
leider auf Leistungen verzichten wir
müssen meine Pension in den Griff
kriegen und sie reduzieren wir müssen
das Rentenniveau wir müssen das
Rentenniveau senken wir müssen die
Renten von den Löhnen entkoppeln sie
dürfen nicht so stark wachsen wie die
Löhne sie müssen weniger stark wachsen
wir müssen die Gesundheitsausgaben mit
mehr Selbstbeteiligung und
Eigenbeteiligung nach Schweizer Vorbild
vielleicht machen wir müssen die
pflegeausgaben wieder irgendwo in den
Griff kriegen früher von 95 hat jeder
das selber klotern können heute kann das
keiner mehr offensichtlich und wir
müssen natürlich auch die Sozialausgaben
in den grundsicherungsbereichen auch
Grundsicherung für alte
in irgendeiner Weise begrenzen so
begrenzen dass wir eigentlich unseren
Kindern sagen können frohen und
ehrlichen erlaubt es das was ihr zahlt
ist ein Fünftel für die Rente das haben
eure Väter und Großväter auch gemacht
das was ihr zahlt ist sagen wir mal 15
Prozent für die Gesundheit das haben
eure Ferien Russland auch gemacht aber
das was die dann bezahlen reicht nicht
aus um die Leistungsniveaus von heute zu
halten und das ist eben halt die
Kernbotschaft wir müssen im Sinne
unserer Kinder auf einen beitrags-primat
weiter deutschen heißt es so auf
konstante preisbeiträge setzen wird dann
wenige Kinder da sind die das bezahlen
dann müssen sich die vielen alten die
das wollen dann immer damit abfinden
dass sie weniger bekommen pro Kopf ist
ja ganz klar damit hast diese plus
Lösungsvorschlag mitgebracht haben dazu
schon mal sehr zielführend wir haben
heute schon öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk gerettet das so System retten
wir jetzt heute Abend auch noch
abgeschafft ich will nicht abschaffen
ich will modifizieren es war auch eine
modifiziert aber nein meine eigentliche
Frage ist wenn sie am Anfang haben sie
auch gesagt dass es System also sie
wollen keine Panik verbreitet nicht gut
ich habe ein bisschen Panik empfunden
bei ihrer These weil ich mich gefragt
habe wie lange hält das System der noch
durch wenn jetzt nichts geändert wird
also wenn er Lösungsvorschlag jetzt
nicht umgesetzt wird also wenn wir
weitermachen wie bisher und wenn wir
weiterhin darauf setzen dass die
Leistungen für die entsprechenden
Leistungsempfänger des Sozialstaates
bleiben wo sie sind dann werden
diejenigen die Sozialstaat finanzieren
dann sehen Sie wenn wir ein Drittel der
Wertschöpfung den sozialbedürftigen
geben der muss das trotzdem von den
anderen wirtschaftet werden ja es muss
ja wirtschaftet werden was wir verteilen
und wenn das dann diese Generation sagen
wir mal überfordert was ihre
Steuerzahlung was ihre Beitragszahlung
angeht dann werden die Lösungen finden
wie beispielsweise eine Kündigung des
Generationenvertrages durch eine
Auswanderung in die Schweiz oder durch
eine sagen wir mal Entscheidung Beamter
zu werden oder durch eine Entscheidung
selbstständiger zu werden oder durch
eine Entscheidung aber zu leisten
vielleicht in irgendeiner klaut die wir
nicht mehr nicht wirklich örtlich
besteuern können weil sie gar nicht mehr
irgendwo stattfindet oder die wir uns
weiter das sind Kündigung des
Generationenvertrages und den haben wir
vor uns wenn wir unseren Kindern nicht
sagen wir verzichten ich denke man
müsste den Kinder also mal allgemein
gesprochen und den Kindern auch sagen
dass der der Glaube an die Allmacht des
Staates an ihr Glaube ist weil ich
glaube das ist das Grundproblem dass man
heute aufwächst viele junge und jüngere
weil sie es auch eingetrichtert bekommen
haben jahrzehntelang von den Regierenden
heute noch drüber da haben mehrere
Generationen dran geglaubt die Rente ist
überhaupt nicht sicher dass man kommt
zwar irgendwas vielleicht 50 Prozent das
muss man dann noch besteuern also warum
macht man nicht ein mutigen Schritt und
stellt es wirklich um auf eine private
Vorsorge nach schwedischen Modell nach
Schweizer Modell teilweise ein
aktienrentenanteil also muss doch ganz
klar sagen wer sich heute darauf
verlasst das verlässt dass er von der
staatlichen Rente seinen Lebensabend
gemütlich gestalten wird können der ist
verlassen und das muss man heute den
Menschen schon früh sagen kümmere dich
darum kümmere Dich vielleicht auch bei
die Krankenkassen und Zusatzleistungen
die wirklich konzentrieren kann auf
basale Leistung
weil sobald ein Politiker sagt er
beschneidet oder er will die Renten
senken oder er will an ihre Pension ran
bitte ja nicht mehr gewählt
dementsprechend eigentlich wollen die
Wähler doch das System haben ich
befürchte da kommen wir an die Grenzen
der Einsichtsfähigkeit des Menschen
solange ich noch gut versorgt werde
schaue ich nicht ob der hinter mir auch
noch ein Schnitzel kriegt und das ist
glaube ich das große Problem aber es
hilft alles nicht wir kommen in eine
Situation wo wir außerhalb dieser
radikalen wahrheitskurve nicht mehr
unsere Probleme in den Griff bekommen
aber wir haben jetzt gerade vorhin
gehört dass wir alle am Hungertuch
leiden ja alle nicht aber viele in der
Armut und dann sollen die Sonne ihre
Rente auf den Weg bringen absolut
utopisch ich glaube auch dass der
gesamte Mittelstand die wollen lieber
mal nach Mallorca fahren oder sonst
wohin ja als dass sie an ihre Rente
denken weil sie in dem Irrglauben sind
dass es klappt ich für mich habe gerade
die Verstorbene Königin von England als
Vorbild die mit 96 quasi an ihrem
vorletzten Arbeitstag munter
eingeschlafen ist ja also und ich finde
Leute sucht euch einen Job aus haltet
euch immer fit es geht ja auch schön
durch die Presse dass ich ein 36 Jahre
jüngere Liebe
ein schönes Land ja lecker gesund bis
zum letzten Tag arbeiten aber wir haben
ja ein eine Finanzierungslücke von 3
Billionen er wird jetzt die Arbeitskraft
von ihnen bis zum bitteren Ende
das wird nicht ausreichen wenn ich
könnte würde ich diesen Stadt retten
aber was ich glaube dass der Hebel im
Kopf ja der Schalter im Gehirn ich habe
einige junge Frauen gehabt die mir
gesagt haben ich möchte mal so werden
wie du nicht wie sie sondern wie ich ja
und das ist selbstständig sein autark
sein und sich nicht immer um allen
Pferde Franz auf dieser Welt kümmern
kümmer dich um dich und um deine Kohle
ja dann hast du ich will nicht sagen das
Geld glücklich macht aber wir reden hier
darum wo über kein Geld ist und da ist
die Misere also hilft Geld wann haben
Sie auch schon überlegt auszuwandern wir
haben ja gerade mehr als einmal schon
nach Dubai da war ich ich war nicht 20
Mal in Dubai vorab vielleicht 15 Jahren
da war das noch nicht so in aller Munde
ja und die ganzen Reisen nach Duba ich
habe alle Malls abgeklappert und da ist
eben auch nicht alles Gold was glänzt du
musst ein Jahr im voraus sein die Miete
bezahlen die so exorbitant ist und du
weißt ja auch nicht ob es läuft oder
nicht also so vorsichtig war ich da
schon lange Rede gar keinen Sinn ich
habe es mehrmals überlegt und mich auch
eruiert und irgendwie ist meine Eltern
haben auch noch gelebt ich hing
wahnsinnig an meiner Mutter und jetzt
bin ich allein ich ich gehe jetzt mal
nach Miami und gucke dann nach dem
Rechnen ich habe sogar ein Angebot von
dieser Firma die diese Blusen herstellt
ja dass er macht doch den Exportmarkt du
kannst so viel Sprachen und du bist so
mobil und deine Leute in Hamburg und
Berlin die schmeißen den Laden schon ich
bin auch dafür vielleicht Werbung ist
gestartet wir kommen aber jetzt noch
einmal zu dem eigentlichen Thema zurück
ja wir waren dann alle aus genau
Regierung keine Wähler mehr und Menschen
sie kennen können wahrscheinlich nicht
einfach auswandern also nein sicherlich
nicht aber ich glaube wenn wir wissen
dass die Sozialausgaben da sind und dass
wir immer mehr Sozialausgaben haben dann
frage ich mich doch warum bekämpfen wir
die Armut nicht so dass die Menschen die
heute in Armut sind aus der Armut
rauskommen wir brauchen in Deutschland
mindestens mindestens vier Generationen
aus der Armut rauszukommen warum kämpfen
wir nicht dagegen an warum schaffen wir
nicht existenzsichern der Arbeitsplätze
zum Beispiel für die alleinerziehenden
Mütter wir geraten in eine Altersarmut
von diesen alleinerziehenden Müttern das
können wir uns ja gar nicht vorstellen
der rechnen noch keiner mit was wir
überlegen müssen das Arbeit auch
attraktiv ist dass Menschen nicht in
einem System verfallen und sagen ich
gehe nicht mehr arbeiten weil ich mich
auf den Start verlasse warum schafft man
diese Arbeitsplätze nicht warum denkt
man nicht darüber nach dass arme Kinder
die nicht genug gefördert werden heute
so gefördert werden dass sie was zu
diesem Sozialstaat dazu leisten ich
glaube wenn wir darüber nachdenken dann
werden wir auch nicht mehr so viel
ausgeben müssen denn prävention ist
immer einfach besser als später dann zu
bezahlen wenn die Kinder süchtig sind
wenn sie Hartz IV oder Bürgergeld
beziehen wenn sie ins Gefängnis gehen
also muss ich Menschen befähigen also
muss ich endlich mal dieses Thema
anpacken damit ich nicht mehr so viel
Menschen in Not und den Arbeitslosigkeit
habe und wir sprechen hier nicht von
Obdachlosen und Alkoholikern sondern wir
sprechen von der Gegenwart und der
Zukunft der Gesellschaft nämlich von
unseren Kindern und die werden ja in
unserem Land immer weniger sie haben
Recht wer soll denn auch die Renten
bezahlen wenn wir immer weniger Menschen
haben wenn Kinder gebären heute ein
unkalkulierbares Armutsrisiko ist dann
ist die Frage was machen wir in unserem
Land falsch der absolut die Frage haben
wir heute auch schon debattiert die
Frage die sich ja jetzt stellt ist
natürlich wie kann man überhaupt noch
den Sozialstaat retten weil wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe können wir eher
weniger Geld ausgeben als noch mehr Geld
auszugeben für rentenhilfen und
Unterstützung für für alles für alles
ist weniger da Punkt wir haben nicht
mehr die Ressourcen um das uns zu
leisten was wir uns heute leisten so und
deshalb müssen wir entsprechend
zurückschrauben wir können auch nicht
selbst wenn wir alle Armut bekämpft
hätten und alles an Armut Weg wäre haben
wir dasselbe Problem es ist so so gering
was das für Beitrag ist das macht keinen
natürlich wollen wir das und sollten wir
das tun aber es ist nicht die DER
Rettungsanker es gibt keinen
Rettungsanker eine Generation eine
Generation ja die die zu einem Drittel
zu einem Drittel das sind wir und sie
auch hier alle zu einem Drittel aus
kinderlosen ich liegen besteht die
überhaupt nichts für das getan haben was
eine Gemeinschaft weiterhin aufrecht
hält die gar keine Kinder haben ja die
die zu einem Drittel zu einem weiteren
Regeln mehr getan
Durchschnitte und ich möchte ja auch
nicht über Einzelfälle hier belehrt
werden der statistische Durchschnitt
kennt keinen Einzelfall so und ein
Drittel dieser Generation ist nicht nur
kinderlos sondern ein weiteres Drittel
ich glaube tatsächlich dass eine Familie
dann komplette ist wenn ein Kind und
Hund ist ja
und nur ein Drittel von uns ticken
richtig die wir beide als war
wahrscheinlich mit zwei drei oder die
Assis unter uns ja die mit sieben
Kindern oder drei Kindern oder sonst
irgendwas das ist das was unser Problem
geschaffen hat sie haben die Leute nicht
mehr gesehen
aber drei sind doch da Reisen auch da
sehr gut und wir haben acht Milliarden
Menschen auf der Welt und davon können
auch wirklich viele Migranten hier
reinkommen die fähig sind ich halte
meinen Freund den Toronto der Tag durfte
nach Kanada rein weil er drei Studien
hat uns manchmal
und ihre 11 Kinder haben meine ganzen
Steuern erstmal gefressen ja
auch ganz selber ausgegeben oder gespart
für mein Alter dann hätte ich kein
Problem im Alter der kann alles so und